I'm going to talk about anarchism today.
And especially,
I'm gonna talk about the
life and death of a one guy.
Somebody I don't admire I on me,
but in a way he represents some aspects
of the origin of modern terrorism in,
in late 19th century Paris.
And I guess if you're gonna
write a book about somebody,
it's not a bad idea to pick someone
who only lived to be age 21, uh,
can make for a shorter book, uh, cause
he was getting, uh, as you'll see,
uh, in 1894. Um,
so, uh, there we go. Um, first of all,
no anarchists.
I'm like,
socialists did not want to capture
the state seize control of the state.
They wanted to destroy the state.
They wanted to abolish the state. Uh,
they viewed a political participation.
And in this way,
there are other like to syndicates as
are propping up a capitalism and its army
defending the interests of wealthy people.
Um,
the first anarchist was
a man called a poodle.
A who's influenced really a
is in the 1850s and 1860s,
uh, and put on, was from, from the east
of France. He was from Bezos Song, uh,
in the east,
and he once wrote a pamphlet
called property is theft.
Uh, in 1841, uh, he met too much
property or unearned property,
was theft. Uh, but it was a
provocative kind of title and he wants,
wrote the following to
be governed is to watch,
inspected to be watched, inspected,
spied upon directed, law-driven,
numbered, regulated, enrolled,
indoctrinated, preached at controlled,
checked, estimated, valued, censored,
commanded by creatures who have neither
the right nor the wisdom nor the virtue
to do so.
To be governed is to be at every
operation that every transaction noted.
Registered, counted, taxed, stamped,
measured, numbered, assessed the license,
authorize, admonish, prevented,
forbidden, a reformed,
a corrected,
punished,
and on the pretext of public utility
and the name of the general interest to
replaced under contribution,
drilled, fleeced, exploited,
monopolized, extorted from
squeezed, hoaxed robbed.
And then at the slightest resistance,
the first word of complaint to be
repressed, fired upon vilified, harassed,
hunted down, abused
club, disarmed bound. Um,
check in prison, imprisoned,
uh, judged, condemn, shot,
deported sacrifice, sold,
betrayed, and to Crown, all mocked,
ridiculed, a derided, outraged,
dishonored that is government debt.
It's,
it's justice that is hits it's morality
now predominant followed by two
important Russian, uh, anarchists,
both of whom I won't talk about,
but who extremely interesting.
And both of whom were Noble's a one as
a guy called Peter Kropotkin and the
other, the terrifying, quite
terrifying. Uh, Mikhail Bakunin.
Um, and they become a quite
important, um, Kropotkin, uh,
who was a gentleman, a geographer, and
once toasted by the, by the king of,
of England, uh, and in the end, uh,
was horrified by the Bolshevik, uh, uh,
a revolution.
He was among those who came up with
the term propaganda by the deed.
That is the belief that, that the
masters were potentially revolutionary.
And it took a single spark,
a single assassination,
a single bomb to start revolution rolling.
And our kiss a assassinated,
depending on how you count it,
five or six or seven heads of state,
uh,
in the late decades of the 19th century,
including a President Mckinley of the
United States who was a shot or stabbed,
I can't remember which in, um, in Buffalo,
New York in 1901,
uh,
that number included as we'll see
in a while, a Saudi council, c, O,
s t a r n o t, uh, who
was the president of,
of France. So I want to
begin with, with a bomb.
And I've had, because of this
bomb years and years afterward,
I've had the rather odd, a
feeling of twice having eaten, uh,
in the cafe restaurant that
my book's subject blew up. Uh,
the cafe a terminus, and it
is a turning point in, uh,
the origins of modern terrorism.
On February 12th,
the 1894 a pale seeing young
man called [inaudible],
prepared a bomb in his room in Paris.
He hid it in his closing along with a
loaded pistol in a knife and he headed
toward the elegant boulevards
near the Paris opera,
which had been completed 20 years earlier.
He wanted to throw the bomb and kill
as many people as possible on restock
before the opera itself,
which as you can see,
resembles a giant golden wedding cake.
There was a fancy ball going on and he
knew he could not get past the guards to
get close enough to claim any victims.
He then checked out the restaurant,
be no followed by the cafe America
and then the most chic of the mall,
the Cafe Dilla pay in the Garland hotel,
which is still there.
He was in some way a flaneur
and intellectual who had
briefly in his life and
something of a dandy,
but if so,
he was an impoverished Flender who lived
on the margins of urban life and who
now came to the grand boulevard,
not just to observe what detached
distance as the flood or did,
but to hate and now to kill.
He moved on finding each place
was not crowded. A crowded enough.
At 8:00 PM,
he reached the cafe Termi nous
right next to the golf Santa, the czar
around the corner from the guard Salazar,
and it's, the cafe was slowly filling
up. He ordered a beer and soon, uh,
another and then a cigar.
And in a rather an anarchist like gesture,
he paid for them is the
small orchestra played on.
About an hour later, he
walked to the doorway, turned,
lit the fuse with a cigar.
He sued the bomb back into the cafe,
which was now very crowded,
already famous for its great expositions.
Paris more than ever identified with
ledger and with consumerism had become a
permanent exposition in itself.
It's boulevards, the staging ground,
as you'll see later in
the course for the belly.
PUK department stores welcome clients
with Dazzling Electric Lights and arrange
shop windows, inspiring Zola to call
them that cathedrals of modernity.
The isles of the department stores were,
as has been argued,
a continuation of the great
boulevards themselves.
In contrast, the poor workers lived along
the narrow grey streets of the calc ta.
Popu there. Uh, this is not a county
pope you there, this is, uh, the,
the terminus that will be in
neighborhoods of eastern Paris.
We're cholera had killed
a as late as 1884.
The rebuilding of Paris by mine in the
fifties and sixties had chased thousands
of ordinary people, uh, by
higher rents to the exterior,
a neighborhoods of northern Paris,
northeastern Paris,
and to their working class suburbs.
But the capital of the world that is
Paris was no longer the capital of
revolution.
Soldiers and Paris seem to be police
and soldiers seem to be everywhere.
And there were indeed many
more of them for that matter.
Ost Mons boulevards were too
wide for barricades to August.
And Wow. The impression is painting
the new boulevards that line, the, the,
that the buildings that lined
the boulevards were cold in,
lined up like soldiers at review.
A nice description of the consolidation
of state power in 19th century France on
May Day 1891 troops fired on demonstrators
killing women and children in the
small industrial town in the north of me.
Uh,
woolens town France may not then have
had strong executive authority because of
the fear of Caesar Ism
after two Napoleon's,
but no other state was so centralized.
And so in the early 1890s did anarchist,
uh,
begin to create small
organizations along the move,
which is the room move tab behind the
Ponti Y'all where a guy calls you on Gob
published one of the anarchist newspapers
at number one 40 here and there in the
Latin quarter, but above
all in Mamacita, uh,
and in these northern industrial
regions and beyond in,
uh, uh, suburbs. Now
the 1880s and nineties,
will as you, you may
already know, uh, we're,
will be remembered as a time of scandal.
The sleazy Panama Canal
scandal and lots of other ones.
The president's son in law is selling
the ledge own donor, uh, et cetera.
And the memory of the Paris commune
loomed large for anarchists.
More than 25,000 people
had been gunned down.
And now from the heights of Moma
and from Bellville, uh, another, uh,
peripheral neighborhood anarchist looked
down on the flashing lights of the
Capitol, and they hated many,
admired the Russian anarchists,
Michael Bakunin, uh, the, uh, who for
whom destruction was quote unquote,
a creative passion that would bring
about the end of the state. Capitalism,
uh, and private property,
uh, the modern state, but,
and wrote with all its terrible means
of action given to them by modern
centralization was becoming
an immense crushing,
threatening reality as those slaughtered
Komi now saw ops close in May of 1871.
And so a wave of anarchist bombings swept
the capital between 1892 in 1894 they
ended with the assassination
of a Saudi council, uh,
in June of that year in Lino,
um,
after two attempts on his life,
King Umberto,
the first of Italy noted
that assassination was
quote, a professional risk,
and indeed he was later
assassinated himself.
Yet many of the anarchists were,
were people of peace. Uh, indeed,
uh, and, and women of peace.
In the case of Louisa Michelle,
about whom you, you can,
uh, uh, can read, uh, for, uh,
for core Plotkin and before Him who'd
all, uh, the goal was the primitive,
the goal was sort of communities that
would exist without the state. Uh,
Kropotkin they had lived in the French
is Johan Mountains in the east and also
in Switzerland.
Uh,
and they're watchmakers seem to get
along fine without the intrusion, uh,
of, uh, of the state. But
yet, as I said before,
it was a Kropotkin who accept it and may
have created the phrase propaganda by
the deed. Uh, sometimes,
uh, attributed to, uh,
the Italian anarchists, Mala Testa,
who had lots of influence in, um,
in Spain,
in Italy and in Argentina who doesn't
look like such a terrifying guy himself,
uh, when you see him there. But again,
the belief that a single act of violence
would be the spark that would bring
social revolution.
Now,
Kropotkin later had doubts about
this and he said, personally,
I hate these explosions,
but I cannot stand as a judge to
condemn those who are driven to despair.
It can.
He had after all an 1880 describe the
importance of permanent revolt by oral and
written propaganda by the knife,
the rifle and dynamite.
Everything that is not
legal is good for us.
Now, dynamite was invented by
that man of the peace prize,
Alfred Nobel in 1868.
And what it seemed to do was
level the playing field. Uh,
it seemed to represent a modern
revolutionary alchemy, uh,
and as a compensation of for many evils,
for humiliation and weakness
for discrimination and
frustration and anger at
social exploitation and injustice.
The German anarchist Johan most who
came to the United States, um, he,
we had written in his newspaper freedom
that it was within the power of dynamite
to destroy capitalism.
Justin had been within the power of,
of gunpowder and the rifle to white
feudalism from the face of the earth.
And American anarchist crowed
before being hung in Chicago,
Haymarket 1886, uh, in given,
given given dynamite to the downtrodden,
millions of the globe,
science has truly done its best work.
The famous
Robert Shoal,
Francois [inaudible] took this to heart.
He had been born in, in non poverty
near Santa tn in 59, his father,
a Dutch mill hand who abandoned his wife
and four children in primary school and
it mass.
He was embarrassed by having closed
shows so shabby that they resembled those
worn by beggars.
He worked here and there,
but periods of unemployment became longer.
He turned toward anarchism
also to grave robbing,
counterfeiting and finally
murder strangling a strange
old hermit who had a lot
of money stashed away in his
house in the hills near Santa Tn.
He was arrested,
managed to escape the police wagon and
went to Paris living under an assumed
name in 1891 police fired on
demonstrators on the boulevard,
p sheep in Paris on the edge of Paris.
Three were hauled to a police
station and they were beaten up,
put on trial and co two condemned
to long prison sentences.
Ravish shoals,
two deeds followed.
He bombed the houses have two of the
magistrates on the boulevard, Sandra math,
very elegant neighborhood. And on
the route of clichy. Uh, what, uh,
on the way home he stopped
in a restaurant called Le v,
v e r y with an accent
on the boulevard Magenta.
A way to remember to scar he had
on his left hand. Three days later,
he went back to the same place
to eat because he'd eaten well.
It took 10 policemen to subdue them.
See this hand,
he told judge and jurors it is killed
as many bourgeois as it has fingers.
He was teen on the 11th of July, 1892, uh,
in the Luau.
And when Brazil several days later,
a destroyed the restaurant.
He killing the pots hall,
the owner leading to the ghoulish punned
that served as an anarchist signature.
Viv Costume,
Ravish Shul.
So terrified contemporaries that for a
time his name became a French verb to
revel show eight [inaudible]
somebody was to dynamite them.
And after his death,
the anarchists of Paris and they're,
they're exiled friends in London
from all over the continent, uh,
debated long into the night.
The wisdom of such attacks would print.
Here, you can see it by
the artists. Charlotte.
Mohan reproduced in a widely read
anarchist newspaper portrayed.
Ravi shoal is a martyr,
his defiant heroic face set
within the frame of a guillotine.
Some sympathizers began to compare
their martyr Robert Shoal to sort of a
violent Jesus Christ,
both Christ and Robert Shoal.
We're 33 when they were executed and out.
An anarchist song sang a song called
La Rava showed that is the song of Rev,
a show to uh,
uh,
the tune of ha a song from the French
Revolution in the great city of Paris
live, the well fed bourgeois
and the destitute who have
empty stomachs but they,
they have long teeth,
long live rava shoal.
Let's dance the robber shoal a
long live the sound of explosions.
So it will be so,
it will be [inaudible]
in his eulogy for a robber Shawl and
anarchist critic art critic Paul, a. Dot.
And literary critic Paul,
a dom warned that the real murderer
robber shul will open an era and it did,
uh,
an anarchist writer outrage.
Public opinion by provocatively stating
what do the victims matter if the
gesture is beautiful.
Bull.
Just a vertical psychosis took hold of
Paris with people of means afraid to go
to red, good restaurants or the
theater and in Nice neighborhoods,
people fearing to rent two
magistrates for fear of lay.
Dina Meteye,
the dynamites hours near
nearly 20 Parisian dailies
carried each installment of
anarchist attack. This is a bomb.
This is a cold meat. It's a,
it's a, it's a, it's a pan. It's
a casserole. Uh, but it's a bomb.
Hundreds of scrawled we, and here's
the first, you know, they, they,
they advantage of this time that the
wagons that did come to, to, to detonate,
uh, and to make safe as best they can,
these objects. And they kept filing,
finding joke bombs and sardine
cans and stuff like that.
And so here's the municipal chemist,
the Guy Calls Ya,
who's checking this out.
Uh,
hundreds of scrawled threats and
which I read, I might, you know,
they're in the archives there,
uh,
arrived to a property owners
and the concierge, uh, uh,
to people of means, uh, uh,
by the Avengers of Robert Shoal a or
an anarchist from the neighborhood,
uh, address to an exploiter
of the proletarian. Finally,
the day when a social justice will
arrive next Sunday, the 1st of May,
you will be blown up,
signed Ladina meat and in Monaca a
benefit dance for anarchist played the
dynamite Polka, uh, as one of the dances,
the well known next act
on the 9th of December,
1893 August of [inaudible],
an unemployed worker distraught and
being unable to feed his family,
tossed a small bomb filled with tax
thumbtacks into the Chamber of Deputies.
His goal was not to kill. There were
several scratches on the deputies,
but to call attention to the plight
of the poor who situations seem to be
getting worse and worse.
He was captured on the spot.
The get your immediately,
instantaneously after a,
a brief trial severed his
head as he defiantly shouted,
the obligatory long live anarchy a meal.
On Ray's father,
a militant Republican who wrote poetry.
He had been elected to the commune
from the 10th, or only small,
and was a member of the central committee
of the Federated National Guard.
And the Paris commune.
He fled under the, uh,
a sentence of death to
Spain. Um, and in Catalonia,
he worked in the mines,
uh,
turning from socialism to anarchism
cause the anarchists were terribly
influential, uh, in Spain, right
through the Spanish civil war. I,
particularly in Barcelona, uh, and
also in under the Sia in the south.
And Meta was born in 1872, uh,
in a suburb of, of Barcelona,
uh, dominated by the textile factories.
He had two brothers fought Shanae,
uh, who, uh, was older, who had the
same name as his father and Judah,
who was 15 in 1894 following
his father's death, uh,
in 1882 from what appear to be
mercury poisoning a madam, he,
uh, returned to Paris with her
children, and it's the region, uh,
in mule became a pupil
of the city of Paris, uh,
receiving the equivalent of a
scholarship, uh, to, uh, school,
uh, outside of Paris. Uh,
his mother bought or had a little bit
of land that had been in the family,
uh, and found, uh, started up in Obash,
uh, right down the street from this.
I was actually an end.
I was actually able to find it to go out
to this place called Braven, which now,
you know, strangely enough is not
all that far from you. Oh, Disney,
but then was truly, uh, in,
uh, in, in the countryside. So,
uh, I mean it only becomes a
scholarship student. Uh, he, uh,
he's very smart.
He gets a certificates of merits in all
the schools he goes to and he gets his
box, his baccalaureate exam,
you passed us as the age 16, uh,
which was a pretty tough to do.
Um, he was examined in physics,
math and chemistry, and he
would put some of the later, uh,
to use as we shall see the last
report on his scholarship red.
He will begin studies next year
at the Ecole polytechnique,
which is one of the grounds
they call the big, you know,
military engineering school.
Extraordinarily hard to get in.
He was classified as Adam deceived
that as he could be admitted.
But after passing one part of the exam,
he failed the oral exam,
but he could have taken it again.
He claimed that one of his friends threw
a stink bomb into the room when he was
taking the exam. Uh, and, uh, you know,
said later that he vowed vengeance on
bourgeois society, blah, blah, blah. Uh,
that wasn't the case. Um, he
took a position with an uncle,
an engineer working on a
water project in Venice,
but he precipitously returned to France.
He dabbled in spiritism trying to
contact, uh, the sole of his dead father.
And that's where we try to move
tables around and, and, and,
and all of that is anarchist friend,
a shot Amato total claim that he lost
his footing and fell into the abyss of
spiritual spiritism even becoming a medium
of incarnation and wasted his health
in such exhausting experience experiments
because he longed for knowledge,
but he left it all behind.
Uh, and, uh, in Paris,
he worked here and there while
living on the margins of urban life.
His brother a false to ne,
uh,
became an anarchist and was a prominent
orchard at the meetings and debates held
in smokey, smokey halls and
cafes on the edge of Paris,
principally more math,
uh, and the full bull, uh,
do tops and in the Latin quarter.
And he went to jail in 1894 for
things that he'd written immediately.
Now,
20 years of old,
20 years of age of what La [inaudible] Mu,
uh,
he was called microbe by his classmates
because it was relatively small a size.
He was Pale,
deep set black eyes as you saw and sport
at the beginnings of a blonde beard on
his chin to go with chestnut hair.
He was devoted to his mother and
would walk or take the train out to a,
not a really nearby station,
uh, to go and, and, uh,
and visit her, uh, and there with a bar,
several tables with workers
drinking wine, the inevitable, uh,
checkered tablecloth, green
shutters, and a red brick roof, uh,
and chickens a poking around. And, um,
laundry hanging out to dry. Uh, as I said,
it was a village and the other 120
francs that a immunotherapy you earned a
month, he gave about a third of his
mother to his, uh, to his mother.
Um, here she is, uh,
down below and there she is up
above on the left, prematurely aged.
Uh, and that is one of
the places that he, uh,
that he lived that we'll
see later where I've,
I've been to everywhere that he lived,
I've got managed to get into the buildings
I've everywhere. He lived a sort of,
you kind of walk around and follow them.
I don't admire him,
but it's interesting to try to,
to try to see what he saw and that's what
I really love about history. Uh, anyway,
so he, he began meeting with
some of the anarchist groups.
He read Kropotkin his great book,
the Conquest of bread as well as
works by Mala Testa and various French
counterparts.
His two targets were private property
and authority to vicious germs,
as he called them.
That formed the base of contemporary
societies that he wrote have to be
destroyed,
eradicated from social life.
He remained an intellectual,
somewhat detached,
arguably from those people who crowded
into these anarchist meetings or who came
to get for once a bite to eat in the
various lectures where soup was served to
the poor afterward.
Um,
in contrast to y'all who loved the
people by almost the guy executed for
throwing the TAC bomb, a Mulatto
remembered immediate, only loved the idea.
He felt a mark estrangement from the
ignorant and survival plebs Plebeians,
uh, a feeling distinctive, uh,
also have a number of literary and
artistic anarchist by whom he met.
Uh, no, no, uh, uh, less, uh,
a painter then can be, uh, uh,
[inaudible] Ho who was a Pizarro
who, who was, uh, an anarchist. Uh,
and,
and mark also was the center of this
sort of literary and cultural anarchism,
uh, the, the anarchism of the
sort of intellectual elite, uh,
who lived in [inaudible] because
it was cheaper and they're,
they're the next generation removed
down to, uh, uh, Montparnasse.
And then when math would already become
the sort of tourist trap it is now
though, it's still has, uh, it's,
uh, it's charms. Um, I mean all,
he was a loner.
He never spoke in public
as far as we know though.
He didn't shout out some things
at one it meeting once. Uh,
he was described later after his
death is the sounds used of anarchy.
Uh,
sounds use was one of them was a cold,
steely guy who had ripped off
his mother's silver during the,
before the French revolution,
who became a member of the
committee of public safety. And uh,
he and Robespierre where
sort of main men of,
of the committee of public safety. Uh,
so he didn't speak like false Janae,
who was a really gifted
orator. Um, and in March, uh,
1893 fortunate gave a speech,
uh,
at this one place where they met over
and over again denouncing the government
class, uh, and the bourgeoisie.
And he appeared to pull a
dynamite cartridge from, he said,
this is our arms. These are our arms and
appear, deploy, pull a dynamite cartridge,
uh, from his pocket. Uh,
it actually was nothing
but a pen or a pen case.
But he was arrested and so was a mean.
Uh,
and m immediately lost his job.
Uh, at that point he worked in,
in the garment industry.
I love this cause here's the,
the root of a song ta in the center
of Paris. And that's still, you know,
the finest, so beautiful from the
1890s that they left it there.
That company hasn't been
there since World War One. Uh,
but that's where
immediately, uh, uh, worked.
But he lost his job after he was
arrested and then, and then released.
He bounced between, um, uh,
between bad jobs once working
as an apprentice and unpaid
watchmaker in order to
perhaps work on timing
mechanisms, uh, for, uh,
for bombs in 1892.
And he always got very good employers,
loved him because he was very smart. He
was, he served as a, as an accountant.
He penned letters and that
kind of stuff. Um, but in 1882,
he briefly served as the manager
for the anarchist literary, uh,
a newspaper. Uh, in the meantime, he
was gathering materials to make bombs.
And learning how to
prepare them that July,
he and he and his brother may have gone
to Santa tn and mom result with the
intention of blowing up the house of the
magistrate in Robichaud is trial down
there. But, and I, I went to
Santa and to try to, uh, you know,
find that if he actually went
there and the police think he did,
but I have no positive proof
of that. Um, anyway, he, um,
he, uh, the police informants
and the police were everywhere.
If you want to see this,
it'll,
Joseph Conrad has a wonderful
novel called the secret agent. Uh,
and GK Chesterton has another one called
a man who would be Thursday in which
all seven anarchist in this antithesis
anarchist group turned out to be policed
spies. And Lennon was just riddled
with police spies, uh, you know,
watching the Dutch and Spanish and French
and Russian and Czech anarchists and
all the others. But anyway, uh,
he was overheard telling somebody,
I didn't put enough nitroglycerin
into this one, uh, and it didn't work,
but I'm gonna put a little more acid
next time and we'll see what happens.
And the police report,
which I've seen assigned him
to the number 318,532, uh,
and so he had a police existence,
which was good for, uh, uh, for me.
Um, the police, as I said, it
infiltrated these groups. Uh,
one of the, the, uh, the,
the police spies who is known as x number
for a reported that the old ways of
the anarchist no longer seem to
be in play that were anarchists,
hadn't used to go to these big halls
where the police were scribbling notes and
identifying everybody was there.
That the ones who had to worry about,
we're not the ones who were
in the hall giving speeches,
but as the one who are looking in the
shadows looking for other people with, uh,
you know, with evil
deeds, uh, as it were, uh,
in mine, they were the ones who
would show up and then leave quickly.
These were the most violent and one is
the ones who are capable of carrying out
propaganda by, uh, the deeds. Uh,
they were not the ob,
the posers, um, or, uh,
the boasters,
uh,
they were off by themselves and they
reflected a debate with an anarchist
circles between the association analysts
who had ended up being cynical lists
and those who believed in the individual
autonomy in individual autonomy that
the single anarchist making
his decision to go out and,
and kill individual autonomy.
And thus,
you know, I use the, the uh,
the description of, of, of,
of this lecture for better
for worse as dynamite club,
but dynamite club was the
perception of our, not the police,
cause they knew better, but of the
public that imagined that, that,
that behind every incident,
every sardine can was in there for various
plot to destroy organized a society.
There was no club,
but there were some violent individuals
capable of minorities within anarchist
movement of doing deeds on the 11th,
backing up one year for reasons we'll
see. The 11th of November, 1892,
an employee of this, uh, of
the mine company of cow Mo,
those mining strikes that John
had catapulted jr has to fame, um,
found a suspicious looking package on
the floor outside the company door at 11
avenue. Uh, Dillup. Aha,
they're 11 up on the left.
This is 1900. This picture I've gotten
into that building to my son and I did,
I would showed him where that he put the
bomb. It's still a very elegant, uh, uh,
uh, elegant building. Um, and
they carried it downstairs,
rather stupidly, place it on the
sidewalk. It's a back entrance.
And a policeman came along and said,
well,
you better take it to the police station.
I'm not noticing that there were a little
powder that seem to be coming out of
this, uh, uh, this, uh, machine is, they
used to call them in those days. Um,
it was a reversible bomb.
It was a bomb not made by a fuse,
but by chemicals. And when they came
together with blow up. And so these,
these poor policemen are carrying
it to the nearest police station,
which is there, no, that's the f the
building now. Uh, you can get into,
it's on the first floor. I love
stuff like that. I just love it.
That's the police station,
which is still there also.
And so they carry it into the, through
the course first courtyard. One guy says,
hurry up, it's heavy. I was a heavy thing.
They put it in, put it down on the table.
Boom. Arms, legs everywhere. Gone.
Five people killed in
the most horrible way.
The bomb had been wrapped in a newspaper.
Uh,
the issue of Luton from June 1st,
1892 which related the story of the arrest
of a meet Ari and his brother and me.
Then when we left Paris the next day
for London, sending along his apologies,
he was a list on a list of 130 suspects.
He hangs around Fitzroy Square,
which now is so expensive. So Charlotte
Street just full of one fancy,
uh,
an affordable restaurant after another.
He hangs around with the anarchists there.
Um,
a friend of Oscar Wilde's
remembered meeting him there.
He spoke some English but not
terribly well once he told people,
today is the anniversary of the dancing
lesson by which he meant bodies jumping
up and down in their
last final agony, uh, in,
in the police station. He was proud
he had exterminated six enemies.
Mulatto said he grew in his own eyes.
He said to himself that his role as
a destroying angel had just begun.
But why didn't they think he
was a serious suspect? Well,
because the policemen that particular day,
that day in November eight, 1892,
he'd gone to work near the Gal,
do know the station of the north.
He had two errands to do.
One was near the Church of the Madeline,
the second with way up by
near the Arc de Triomphe,
his boss gave him some money to do these
errands and policemen tried to do the
same thing and said that he could not
have gone back to his house in Moscow to
the fifth floor roof at home. It
doesn't matter. I love this stuff.
And got the bomb gone all the way
back down to the avenue local Aha.
And then finished his errands and got
back in two hours and 15 minutes pop. Oh.
So I did it.
I replaced a tram way and
only booths with, you know,
buses and Metros.
And I replaced a carriage.
I never take cabs with a cab and my cab
couldn't turn left on the avenue loop
high. So I subtracted
11 minutes. I paused,
I couldn't get that day into the one of
his houses where we put the bomb. Um,
and I came back in about two
hours and 15 or 16 minutes.
Somebody did the same thing in 1894 and
said he certainly could have done it
anywhere anyway.
Old immediately is off in London now.
Um, let, I'm just trying to now
to imagine what he imagined,
what converts them to anarchism was the
appalling a gap between the wealthy and
the poor in Paris and other places.
Uh, the heritage of his father, uh,
of course with some,
had something to do with it.
Never had people lived it
up and such flamboyant, uh,
want to get even say egregious
ways, uh, as in Paris,
in the belly book,
the so called gay nineties.
Now that the nostalgia for that is,
is a creation really of how horrible
things would be later with world war one.
But, but still the, the belly pope
was not bell for very many people,
but what leads him to anarchism is,
uh,
is that everywhere he lived.
And that was the only place,
the exception in a minute ago,
which was near the busty everywhere
he lived was on the edge of Paris.
And everywhere he lived,
the facades of the buildings are still
the same is one that's near a Momar.
Ah,
and they're building sock recur.
This is from that same time the hadn't
been completed yet, but it's, it,
it's big bell drowning out.
The whole city hadn't been put in there,
but this soccer career was built where,
uh,
where the commune had been,
had started and it was a,
it was seen as a monument of penance
for the government of the moral order.
And so that they hated this and
they refer constantly to this. Uh,
they have fantasies a as all,
I wrote a novel called Paris,
but he in 1898 a,
which is modeled after a meal,
Henri and some of these other people.
And,
and the brother of this
priest who liked it, you know,
rem record is losing his religion.
He has these fantasies about blowing up,
sock recur and Emilio and relived near
there, he lived in the Ruby at home,
which is now fairly sheikh.
He live in the top floor up there.
That's where he went to get the bomb. And
then he moves into this place. It says,
Vila full share hasn't flow for sure.
And that's not fancy at all. Uh, but,
and this is the same facade. He
lived on the inside there, uh,
in 1894 and I went up there cause I, you
know, I gotta see, I gotta, I gotta See,
and this is a pretty, uh,
a sketchy neighborhood and
there are a lot of d there,
a drug deals going on here. And I didn't
want to look like, uh, uh, seek on CV.
You know, I'm a plainclothes
cop and I don't want it to last.
I don't wanna look like a wealthy
tourist either. And so, you know,
I kind of hid behind the truck and
took pictures and I walked in and said
something like, so seller Liga and
uh, you know, every day I had to see,
but when you walk out of this,
that's how you got in.
That's 1894.
When you walk out of this,
you turn right and there is the park of,
of,
of bevy and down below
the plus lateral cat,
when he would lose his
head and he looked out,
he was lucky he couldn't see the tour
Montparnasse uh, which didn't even exist,
but he could see symbols that he hated.
There was a tool he fell that had
only been there for the Eiffel Tower,
been there for five years.
There was the Ponti on where that the
State is commemorated its heroes and there
was no true dom,
which he hated as well.
And so he once wrote that
love can lead you to hate.
He wrote that before.
He's gay teens and he hated,
he loved humanity in the abstract.
He loved his mom too.
But he, he loved humanity and he
hated the state. And so he sent out,
he set out to kill. So these are, uh,
these are sort of visual signifiers,
I guess in the new cultural history.
They would call them these buildings
upon which are these monuments that he
looked down, uh, and uh, and
hated. If you've read, uh,
Balzac's old Gfi,
oh,
ever in your reading career that
at the very end of the story,
Rosti neck is up at perilous as cemetery.
And in the poor parallel,
she has not poor but,
but the area around it is,
and he gestures down to western Paris,
the fancy Paris,
and he says the equivalent of its
war between you and me. Now Baby.
But he wanted to make the big time.
He wanted to sleep with the right people.
He wanted to,
to just do better and better for himself.
Immediate already says that, points down
in those neighborhoods. And he says,
this war between you and me now baby.
And he meant it and he built bombs.
And he went out to,
uh,
to kill a,
at a time when anarchist deeds
were being celebrated by some,
uh, anarchists. The explosive device
that he threw into the cafe. Termi News.
February, uh, 1894, hit a chandelier,
then a marble table and fell
to the ground, exploding.
20 people were wounded of
whom won. The, uh, later died,
broken glass paces of pieces of, of tables
and chairs, blood and injured people.
Fear was everywhere.
Uh,
and our architect had five wounds,
a draftsman,
17 Ari had seen,
I had been seen.
He did after all sip just his second
beer first also. Uh, and at one point,
not, not, so he wouldn't be caught. Let's,
so we can rule out indirect suicide,
uh, which I'll talk about just
briefly in a minute. He said, Oh,
where's the scoundrel that
did this, uh, and runs away.
And he's chased by policemen,
by an apprentice barber, by, uh,
a controller from the,
from, uh, the trauma way.
And they finally catch him,
uh, around the corner from, uh,
from the Garth's, none
of those are, and the,
and he fires point blank with his pistol.
He also had his knife,
had that poison on it as well. Uh, uh,
one policeman called [inaudible], uh,
is, was very lucky to have escaped, uh,
uh, with his life because his big
wallet with was hit by, uh, by one of,
of these shots.
And so he's put in prison
here in the Cosia Gov,
and that cell no longer exists that he
was in now don tall and Robespierre and
Marie Antoinette and, and, uh, Louis
the 16th, we're also in this prison.
And one of the great sources
about this guy's life was, uh,
the prison guards because they're trying
to get information out of him and he
tries to convert them to anarchism. And,
and you know, they have very interesting,
uh, kind of, uh, of relationship.
Um, the first night he was in prison,
a friends of his broke into his
room and took out enough, uh,
dynamite to make 14 or 15 other bombs.
And so Paris is to say the
least on a high alert. Um,
and so, um, on the, uh, is,
was put on a trial, uh, and in, uh,
flourish. Uh, he, uh,
I saluted anarchism and gave a
declaration, a four anarchism, uh,
that, uh, was red. Uh, and
it's still red, uh, today.
Um, where he says, you have Gary to
deaths in Spain. You have a hung us,
and in Germany you have shot us,
uh, here and there you have, uh, uh,
you let you have a,
a guillotine destined France.
But what you can never do as extinguished
and are key because it's, uh,
it's, um, it's roots are too deep.
Uh, not surprisingly, he was
condemned to, uh, to be executed.
Um, and that he was on
the 21st of May, 1894,
uh, and an early morning at
4:00 AM four in the morning.
And the,
the,
the executioners all come from the same
family in this guy called [inaudible]
was, it was the execution. I got to
go back to that woman in a minute. Um,
this is DBA who was called Mr [inaudible],
who was the chief executioner.
And for him, one where execution was
just, you know, just one more execution.
The last public execution and France
was 1936. The last execution in France,
uh,
using a gay teen of course
come WTF was 1972 or 1973,
I can't remember what date.
And you know,
in the chill of that morning where
people paid for paid for, uh, uh,
seats on the roof.
And there were,
there were little children whose parents
bought them seats as if they were on
the roof as if you're outside Wrigley
field in watching the cubs from a,
from a roof far away, uh, uh,
executions were festive
events for those people.
Also finishing there other nights.
And there was always sort of, uh,
uh, uh, some speculation about
when this is going to happen,
when is he finally going to be executed?
And the scene which I've tried
to recreate in this book of,
of deep layer of the wagons with
the wood of justice showing up and,
and with the apprentices doing their
work and putting up this guillotine, uh,
as if you're putting together this,
this basically perfect toy that didn't
need any nails because everything fit
together so well. Uh,
you know, they're really,
this guillotine scenes were so important
for anarchist also because it's part of
the idea of martyrdom,
a revolutionary immortality.
And now this comes from a Christian
religion also, doesn't it?
The execution scenes. Uh, you
know, I, again, I mean, I, you, I,
you see what I'm saying in
that, but, but, but the,
the scenes of the martyrdom and the use
that anarchist put to this are still,
uh, uh, are still rather, um,
rather important. Now, uh,
was this a form of indirect suicide?
He'd fall in love with the wife of an
anarchist and her building is still there
too, ironically, not far away from
the place where he was executed.
And he hit on her and they would go out
with the husband to his obash and he per
word reclaim as love and, and
she kind of blew them off. Um,
it was an indirect suicide.
No,
obviously not because he tries to escape
at the end and then she tell you no.
And real anticipation of the modern life,
she is out giving interviews to the
journalists after his execution. Uh,
she's saying, oh, he loved me so much
and, and, and one can well understand why.
You know, I, the whole thing was
just, just, uh, incredible though,
but it was not any kind of indirect,
a suicide at all.
But what do I mean about the origins of
modern terrorism? What was new about it?
Well, a couple things. Rava Shul vial,
we're very poor. Robert Shaw was a
pullover tip, a sad sack. Viola was not,
he was very honorable person.
Most of the people in Western Europe,
there are some exceptions in, in, in the
Russian case, but these were an anarchist.
It's a group called Neuro Novo
People's will. Um, we're, uh,
we're ordinary workers and me,
don't worry with an intellectual,
he was an intellectual.
That's new.
But that's not as important
as what else was new.
Instead of targeting a head
of state or a uniform person,
as other anarchists had done,
he just picked people who
were having a beer, petty,
bourgeois,
the hated because they propped up
capitalism and through the bomb at them
knowing he was gonna kill a lot of them,
he sat there and looked at them.
There's a very amazing scene in battle
of Algiers and the movie metal jurists
where this woman's going to place a bomb
and she's looking at people that are
going to die because of
what she is doing there.
And he looked at these people and
he said, uh, I'm gonna kill you.
I'm going to kill you because I love,
I hate.
And that's really new about it.
Is it worth at all musing
about what this has to do with,
uh, with, uh, modern
terrorism? I don't know,
just a, a few, uh, uh, reflections. Uh,
there is no doubt about that, that
there are some connections. If you take,
you know, a psalm of
enlightened, for example,
he announced for it as everybody knows
and the late nineties that he'll attack
civilians, American civil billions,
just like American military people.
That's perfectly obvious.
Um, that, uh, another, uh,
another connection is within modern
terrorism. I mean, you have this,
the of alliance between intellectuals,
students and, and, and, uh, uh,
people who are simply a down and out.
I mean, there are big differences also.
I mean the suicide bombers is something,
you know, it's very different but,
but still there are things that are,
we're thinking about third. And you know,
there's the whole idea of revolutionary
in mortality that you kill people.
You die and you have
revolutionary immortality. Uh,
for many a fundamentalist
terrorist you pass into,
into this immediately into
this nirvana fourth, uh,
both set of terrorist target,
a powerful enemy,
a structure they set out to destroy a
tariff and tried to kill one warrant,
a thousand goes in old Chinese, uh, uh,
a proper and they want to
tack the state and capitalism.
I in the case of the anarchists and the
targets are perfectly obvious in the
case of uh, uh, of contemporary
terrorists as well.
Sif dynamite like bombs are seen
as leveling the playing field.
You attack, you can prove that you are
strong. When in reality you are our weak.
They demonstrate the powerful states
are vulnerable even to small groups of
determine, uh, determined,
uh, uh, anarchists.
Next also these groups,
as I said,
their tendency is always to try to
find one person running the whole show.
It's absolutely not the case in the case
of the anarchist, as I already said,
nor is it the case now, uh, as well.
So the French government then and
officials now have a tendency to look for
centrally organized,
massive conspiracy and salvage,
acknowledging this role of small groups
or even isolated individuals undertaking
locally organized or freelance, uh, uh,
operations and our kids to repeat always
emphasize the full autonomy of the
individual. Indeed the potential and
murderous individual as the case,
as I've said, and you
know, I obviously, uh, uh,
to test everything that the
medial Henri, uh, stood for,
but I've tried to
understand his, his, um, uh,
hatred yet.
There's one more other,
there's one more thing
that could be added to,
is that when you think
of the word terrorism,
the word terrorism was originally
applied to actions taken by the state to
terrorize.
The terror was terrorizing
opponents in the French revolution.
And it's often forgotten that the vast
majority of victims of terror are victims
of state terrorism.
And the anarchist hated the state
because they'd seen up close what state
terrorism did in the wake of the Commun.
And the beating up of the police, uh,
clichy, uh, the massacre of
the innocence of these women,
young women gunned down,
uh,
during the strike in the north or man
demonstration in the north in 1891,
uh, must be remembered, uh, during
the 1890s, anarchists attacks,
which were terrible, killed a maximum
of 60 people. Tragic wounding more than,
than 200. But if you look at non,
if you look at state terrorism, uh,
the ratio of somebody has figured
out stands at approximately 262, one,
260 victims of state terrorism as opposed
to one victim of this horrible thing.
Terrorism has become part
of the political process,
what has been called a adults
macabre or sort of macabre dance, uh,
uh, between states and
their fiercest opponents.
The two interact dynamically
and need each other.
The hatred of dissidents is only foot
further stoke by the overreaction of
authorities. Uh, it's simply,
uh, uh, encourages attacks.
And certainly this is not, of course I'm
political science, but there are over.
But the reaction of the United
States government and other
governments, uh, to, uh,
the,
the horrible,
horrible tax and September 11th
are a pretty good example of that.
When, uh, when states take tactics,
swell the hatred of their opponents
by, uh, by abusing prisoners,
by torturing prisoners and
by that sort of thing. Uh,
that line between that goes all the
way back to two Spain of the 1890,
the first decade of the 20th century, back
to the Paris commune before that. And,
uh,
unfortunately to are very day.
That is a story of [inaudible]
see you on Wednesday.